herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ihr seht ist schon im titel ein
tag essen wie ein millionär ist es gebe
ganz viele videos zum thema essen und
ich dachte mir wäre es nicht interessant
einfach mal ein tag um zu schauen wie
man sich danach fühlte hatte silvester
deshalb brauchten die auswärtige braut
wird vielleicht hatte ich auch ein
bisschen lust drauf weil ich würde mir
hat niemals dass so können im alltag was
ich jetzt in diesem video essen werde da
haben wir mal so kaviar hummer
rindersteaks das wird alles heute
gemacht ich mache alles selbst also ich
werde nicht essen gehen weil ich glaube
dann fängt es an richtig teuer zu werden
wenn du diese sachen essen geht dann
kann es kommt jetzt vergessen ist die
halle deshalb brauche ich jetzt auf
jeden fall energie und protein und da
grüßt sich der geneigte millionär
natürlich erstmal zum heiraten eine
flasche city oder kostet drei euro für
500 milliliter oder so glaube ich
einfach das beste was in der welt ich
probiere direkt mal wahrscheinlich
möchte ist so viel besser als normales
wasser schmeckt sehr bald mit nach geld
das ist das perfekte das dritte gleis
mit deckel nicht jetzt dann habe ich
dazu minipli fragt mich nicht warum die
standen im regal direkt neben dem kaviar
ich habe mir vor ich habe ja geholt
damit kann man natürlich auch komplett
überzeugen
der hat dafür wieso acht euro gekostet
für dieses kleine ding wohl gemerkt habe
du kannst auch kaviar für 100 euro das
kann ich ja in dem video essen wäre
milliardär wird dass hier zwei user dann
habe ich noch greenpeace mit frischkäse
sagen aber das klingt nicht so special
und ich bereite mich hier die kleinen
mini ist machen wir dazu noch einen
italienischen cappuccino tippen jetzt
einmal in den frischen philadelphia
jazzdance prämie dann einfach immer
belächelt so groß ist
dies werden wir millionäre sind ja auch
globalisiert und wir zählen natürlich
auch unter einer dichten nebels ist
klein schon teuer dieses knapp 810
jetzt haben wir hier die kwa pärchen und
treiben jetzt auf unsere linie die
bodenständige youtube werfen natürlich
keinen krieg zulassen leichter das ist
ja auch ein brunnen geblieben
ganz im ernst also geht es hier wirklich
das finanziell gut wie du sagst weil ich
mein was sie denn
denn frühstück selbst nein nein ich habe
doch gesagt nicht verkaufen
[Musik]
videotheken kommen zum gelingen der früh
spaß ist falsch um 180 grad richtig
bringt zum arbeiten gedreht kommt es gar
nicht dem was beide seiten setzen
so sieht ungefähr aufgabe millionär ist
was sie gerade gesehen hab ich nehme es
erstmal ein stück von dem café ein stück
von dem viel wasser dann werde ich jetzt
den ersten kaviar happen probieren will
man gespannt wie das schmeckt ich glaube
sehr salzig ok-chef die modewelt deshalb
so viel geschmackliche dimension
wirklich wirklich sehr mit frischkäse
mit dem derzeitigen kader dazu noch so
diese nächte sie story nicht dass es
wirklich über geil ich muss auch sagen
die millionäre haben barrique cool
gemacht bevor es ihn überhaupt gar weil
im prinzip ist gar ja selbst so wie
diese bande von barrett team arbeitet
auch in einem poppen dieser mann hat
einfach diesen fake diese theorie hin ja
was soll ich sagen das wird ein sehr
leckeres frühstück kostet auch nur
solide dasteht wenn man es irgendwo im
rechten raum oder kaffee essen würde ist
wahrscheinlich 30 40 euro kosten diese
dinge muss man aber auch gar nicht mögen
also dass das nicht was jeder macht doch
keinen fall
[Musik]
unsere leute die restlichen drei hatten
es sich jetzt aber auch und dann sehen
wir es beim mittagessen wieder
entspannen dass es geben wird so weil es
zeit fürs mittagessen wundert euch nicht
über den location wechsel wir sind bei
unserer familie weil wir die kurz
besuchen aber natürlich habe ich mir
trotzdem was mitgebracht um zu kochen
entsteht schon den job und die falle
denn alles dreht sich um dieses kleine
schwarze mädchen ihr seht ihr jetzt 22
gramm 20 euro hat das gute stück
gekostet und ich hätte es glaube ich gar
nicht will kann wenn ich so gesehen
hätte es ist ein trüffel und jeder weiß
glaube ich trüffel sind sehr wertvoll
und luxuriös ich mache eine ganz
einfache trüffel passte einfach nur
sahnesoße spaghetti dann reite ich ein
bisschen trüffel rein und legte am ende
noch so ein paar gehobelte triple
scheiben brauche ich das mache also dass
nur seine benutzer einfach damit wir
diesen edlen trüffel geschmack das uns
ganz darauf konzentrieren können und ich
würde sagen du bist vom geist wir legen
direkt lust auf das wasser kocht
das heißt nur am rhein kam auf neun
minuten
wir fahren schon schön heißt
wir werden sie nicht zu lange bei dieser
hitze lassen aber den marlies in die
soße frischen pfeffer hinein und
ansonsten kommt neben bisschen sei es
ganz viel anderes rein geht vor allem
darum das schön reduziert werden jetzt
konstant rühren dabei ich kann schon
verstehen warum so reiche leute in der
regel nicht selbst kochen sondern
einfach alles flüssig machen lassen
es macht zwar spaß gekommen aber ich
finde das allerschlimmste kommen ist das
aufholen und da oder
höchstwahrscheinlich jedem der gerne
kocht auch so wenn es aber fertig ist
glaube ich werden wir belohnt weil es
wird bestimmt sehr sehr gut schmecken
doch ein problem ist wirklich die sahne
relativ weit zu reduzieren ich mache ja
schon runter auf stufe 3 führen haben
wir jetzt die reibe nicht wer schon mal
anfangen denn die sahne während sie
reduziert ein bisschen trüffel
hineinzuschreiben wow letzten alben
trüffel rhein gelegen das waren 13 euro
die ich hier ein geringer zehn euro kann
man sich eben schnell verrät wertstoffe
den ich hier habe hat einen kilopreis
von 800 euro nicht mehr feierlich direkt
in das ist bei männern ist ziemlich
wertvoll es ist erde aber teure mir zur
erde abgerechnet für 800 euro das kilo
bestimmt sowie den städten sind okay wir
probieren jetzt hier so fein raspeln
davon abzuschneiden weil das sieht dann
das lässt das ganze richtig teuer
aussehen am ende wieder so frische
raspeln von schwarzem trüffel drauflegen
sieht geil aus rom ein gottesdienst teil
schafft und alle rezepte die ich heute
mache sind zwar sehr teuer aber auch
recht einfach
also wenn ihr zufällig und fast häufiger
tat und machte
ich probiere jetzt glaube ich einfach
mal so ein scheibchen von dem trüffel
deshalb machen so richtig lustig finde
der riecht auch fast ein bisschen
schokolade das ist wirklichkeit
wir sind jetzt so gut wie fertig
halberstadt ruhm sie ließen es die
nudeln ab das gehen wir die direkt
hierzu zu der sahne trüffel soße dazu
die portionen von sieht aber hier bei
den nudeln wenn wir kurz anhalten sieht
man hier drinnen diese kleinen trüffel
elemente und das ist was das ganze ist
ein teuer macht
[Musik]
so leute da legen wir jetzt ein paar
griffe dies ist drauf einfach nur damit
ihr seht ihr bescheid wird das des
millionärs essen leute eine portion
nudeln die aber im restaurant
wahrscheinlich 20 25 euro kosten würde
für sei es was ja lass dir schmecken ich
richte die anderen teilen danke leute
und da ist das ding sieht sehr edel aus
ich hab eine portion für ich bin reich
und dass wir eine millionärin portionen
für ich bin ich und habe unter hunger
das sieht sehr gut aus
manche sachen sind echt geil welt so
simpel sind viele leute ihr seht hier
ist es noch am dampfen was das geld
jetzt probieren nehme hier eine gabe
man riecht jetzt wirklich richtig den
trüffel ich probiere richtig gut ich
habe ordentlich pfeffer rein gehauen
ich habe jetzt ein paar gabel gegessen
und ich muss wirklich sagen das ist so
einfach und so nah ist das ist wirklich
so das perfekte flex essen also wenn man
irgendwie date hat oder sonst was und
sagen wir dass man kocht und irgendwie
eindruck schinden will oder irgendwie
für die familie kauft oder so dann holt
euch einfach einen rüffel macht das weil
es so simpel das einzige problem ist ein
triple zu bekommen ich musste nämlich
extra in einen italienischen ein forst
großhandel fahrenden frische trüffel zu
bekommen in köln aber es hat sich
gelohnt und es ist auch in dem ihr es
beim abendessen wieder so leute wie sie
essen angekauft und fürs abendessen
können sich so ein millionär noch mal
was ganz besonderes also
wirklich ich habe keine kosten gescheut
wir werden heute zum abendessen hommage
wenzel rinderfilet und champagner
allein diese worte auszusprechen klingt
schon unfassbar teuer glaubt ihr das ist
nicht ganz günstig weil die samt
einzukaufen aber ich werde dann wird
sich ja sonst nichts das einstecktuch
sitzt bei kontor ist auf jeden fall
gespart um sich jetzt hier ein letztes
mal zu fahren also wieso du alter
zerstörter wir haben jetzt hier die roma
schwänze weil wir so dafür sie gleich
schön auflegen können okay der gewiss
vorgeheizt und wir legen jetzt auf
meinte erklärt ist verschwunden die
kommunikation ist auch so ein bisschen
farbe bekommen unsere drehen jetzt
einmal auf die andere seite
wie sind ihre regale wieder dort reden
ich bin ein bisschen bescheuert und
marko marin das millionär bin und teuer
ist kann man es nachvollziehen ich weiß
hier ist unsere flasche champagner ist
natürlich die teuerste dies überhaupt
kaufen ja die probleme zu eröffnen
vorbei ich habe inzwischen so super oft
macht inhalt mit erst magnifique wir
haben uns dreimal so unnötig an
silvester
champagner geholt und sonst habe ich
nicht allzu viel champagner erfahrungen
dann probieren die rauszubekommen
heute schießt selbst
nun hat man dass sie sagen sie jetzt
fertig ist
nach oben und damit sie verziehen leute
heißt das ding die grillplatte mit einem
400 ramon trikot und oma schwänzen das
hat allein nicht so zu kaufen 35 euro
gekostet das heißt dass hier in dem
restaurant komplett oberkellner serving
treffern wie hier vor mir ich weiß gar
nicht wo ich anfangen soll ich glaub ich
fange an mit so einem stück vom von
einem hummer schwanz unglaublichen ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass wir das jemals
mal kochen oder ein bisschen weiter wird
dazu wir probieren
okay war ich verstehe schon warum das so
teuer ist weil es hat wirklich wirklich
den geschmack den man mit nichts anderem
also ich kenn dich und geschmack
geschmack und nichts anderes
das ist schon echt special ich könnte
man schreckt von dem motto game und
schon sehr lecker vorleute millionär
selbst schon gleich schlecht glaube ich
kann man kein bisschen böse ich brauche
der dow jones fällt also hauptsächlich
sagen wollte nicht immer leicht bereich
kelheim bonewitz partner seite würden
wir das niemals so selbst machen weiß
einfach viel zu teuer ist und das ist
obwohl ich selbst zubereitet hat würde
ich das ganze essen geht sonst was wie
gesagt wer ist unfassbar teuer aber es
ist schon besonders
keine ahnung ich glaube wenn man
besondere anlässe hat wie zum beispiel
dieses youtube-video
da ist es schon cool so was mal zu essen
und diesen anlass noch mehr bedeutung zu
schenken aber es ist komplett
übertrieben was im alltag zu essen also
ich bleibe auf jeden fall lieber bei
gucci sandwiches und nudeln mit
tomatensoße im alltag aber das ist schon
echt echt echt lecker ich lasse mir
schon ein bisschen schmecken leute und
wir sehen uns gleich wieder okay leute
das ist jetzt das letzte bisschen ich
bin richtig gesagt ich meine ja die
portion museen ist es komplett overkill
gewesen mein fahrzeug zu diesem tag ist
einfach komplett tracy wie viel geld für
essen ausgeben kann ich muss auch
wirklich wirklich sagen dass es sehr
interessante erfahrungen waren alles war
sehr lecker und ich weiß ja dass man es
nicht oft nach dass man das nicht
deutlich gemacht dass man sich sowas
können dass er hat es mir auch
persönlich wirklich spaß man das video
zu machen weil es hat einfach nicht wahr
die ganzen zusammen zu testen und zu
bereiten wird aber trotzdem sagen dass
das nicht für mich für jeden tag wäre
auch einfach weil es zu teuer ist aber
wenn ich vielleicht mal video sehen
wollt einen tag im leben eines
millionärs also nicht einen tag essen
werden
ja dann vergewaltigt den like button bei
einer milliarde likes mit spaß also wenn
ich merkte dass sie da bock drauf habt
dann bringe ich das und dann werde ich
schauen dass ich irgendwie im einen sehr
exklusiven lifestyle für einen tag lebe
also dass sie sich auf einem boot stelle
im wichtigen autos fahren oder sonst was
ja leute wenn es euch gefallen hat las
gerne leichter
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
macht's gut und bis 1